but you say your relationship with Ted
Harbert was the guy who used to run e
you said over the course of four years
that he ended up annoying you I remember
meeting him and he used to eat those
like light ruffles
you know like half calorie Ruffalo sure
what a ruffles ruffles have ridges from
the potato chips right he and you
thought it was cute when he ate potato
chip like an autistic response wasn't
rigid they doing
I remember the commercial he well said
of Ted yeah he had those that he would
dip them into salsa like pina but the
canned salsa not like pico de gallo like
thick gross canned some [ __ ] and in the
beginning I had never seen anybody dip
potato chips in salsa okay I was like
that's funny
and that's cute but it was cute yeah
like oh I see people dip tortilla chips
into sauce I'm learning new things and
by the end of that relationship every
time I saw that [ __ ] salsa come out
and he would break the chips into tiny
little like the tiny little pieces and
shovel so much [ __ ] salsa onto the
bike his thumb again song and then to
shove it into his mouth this gargantuan
pile of [ __ ] and I would just look at
him and go I [ __ ] hate you oh you're
so honest I hate you